there are a few things I do when I'm
feeling very susceptible to depression
they're really quick pick me ups just
something that I do to lift my spirits
instantly if you commit to it you can
end up having a lot of fun the most
common thing I do is to break out into
song let's get down to business to
defeat the Huns did they send me kitty
oh when I asked for songs or dance dance
dance the pain oh I preferably on a pole
well
and it's hard but go out for a walk no
seriously go out for a walk there's no
Wi-Fi out there get off the internet I
know it's a little ironic considering
you're on the internet right now trying
to figure out how to feel better but I
actually downloaded a website blocker
extension for Google Chrome so Twitter
and Facebook are not accessible to me
from 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. and you know what
it's really nice like I didn't realize
how unhappy being on the internet made
me until you disconnect so try
unplugging for a while and see if that
helps you now this last one is a little
weird but when you laugh and smile when
you don't feel like it and you act a
fool
eventually you actually start laughing
just make sure no one sees you because
then you look like a psychopath anyway I
hope some of this helps and obviously if
you're suffering from like severe
depression or chronic depression talk to
a doctor about possibly going on
antidepressants especially if you are
having like serious suicidal thoughts
all right I will see you next week and
oh I forgot one cuddle with a kitty yes
come lick idiot if you don't have a
kitty adopt two kitties their depression
cured I have found the cure for
depression and it's cats okay well I
will leave all that out
stealth I've got them yeah man you must
be swift as a coursing River with all
the great tackle be a mess we're gonna
take on a raging fire excuse us deductr
up the low feel better